- Thank you guys so much for coming.
I really appreciate your support
in coming out to re:Invent
and coming to see our talk.
So if you've been alive in the last year,
you've probably heard about Gen AI,
you've probably heard
about agentic revolution
that's been going on, and
hopefully you've also heard
about Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
and hopefully that's why you're here,
because that is the topic.
And we're gonna talk a little
bit about what it means
to build multi-tenant SaaS
agents in Amazon Bedrock,
Bedrock, (laughs) Amazon
Bedrock AgentCore.
Ah, that's a good start.
So with that, I want you
to think a little bit
about any SaaS applications
you've built or any that you've used
and how they've evolved over the years
and the best practices as we know them.
And we'll get into a little
bit about what it means
to take those same practices
and apply them to Agentic solutions.
My name is Bill Tarr,
I'm a principal partner
solutions architect,
and I'm lucky enough to
be joined by Ujwal Bukka,
senior principal architect,
senior partner solutions
architect with AWS.
With that, before we get started,
this is a 400 level
session, so we're going
to spend some time digging into code,
showing actual examples.
We will set the table a little bit,
but we do have an expectation.
You'll have some background a
little bit in terms of coding,
in terms of perhaps a little bit
around AgentCore already.
So with that,
I wanna talk about
something else really quick.
I want you to know that
there's also a workshop
that reflects almost all of the practices
as we've talked about
them in this session.
So if you like getting your hands dirty,
getting into the code,
figuring out what's going on,
this is going to be today and tomorrow,
it's listed as session
full in the catalog.
Don't hesitate to go wait in line.
This is a great workshop.
All of the things you see today
and even a little bit more are
reflected in that workshop.
And really it is the
basis of this entire talk.
And if you aren't somebody
who can likes workshops,
or you don't want to go do the
workshop, you can just go out
to GitHub and you can grab the code.
So there's an actual code base
with actual working code
that is behind this.
This isn't vaporware, this
isn't us waving our hands.
This is a real solution with
a workshop you can attend.
And if you can't get
to the workshops here,
reach out to your AWS SSA.
They can help you get
access to this workshop.
So what is this workshop that we built?
Well, here's the sample architecture.
I don't wanna spend too much time on it,
but I want you to see
this in the beginning,
because what you're gonna
see is a number of components
that will be reflected
throughout this entire talk.
So you'll see that there's
an AgentCore runtime.
This is where our code lives
and this is where where we're
gonna execute our agents.
We have several agents.
There's gonna be an orchestrator agent
that's gonna call a knowledge base agent,
a log analysis agent, and a coder agent.
Why?
Because it's going to help
us solve code problems
as they occur.
So it's actually going to be able to code
to a knowledge base, look
at our documentation,
see how the code should operate.
It's gonna be able to go to
our logs through Athena and S3
and examine our logs
and see if we can find a
reason that the problem
is happening and as a coder agent
that perhaps can actually create code,
or review code as we wanna roll fixes out.
Around all of these,
we have the tools that
live in AgentCore Gateway,
we're gonna get it into what it means
to manage tools in AgentCore.
We're gonna talk a little
bit about AgentCore identity.
What does it mean to manage authorization
and authentication in a SaaS
solution in a multi-tenant
solution and in an AgentCore itself?
And then finally, observability.
I wouldn't wanna do any talk
around multi-tenancy without
talking about observability
and how we implement the ability
to get visibility into the
operations of our solution.
With that, I said I was
going to talk a little bit
about SaaS.
We're gonna focus in on
five main SaaS architectural
challenges that we see
with the customers we talk
to who are building SaaS today,
Before you even think about agents.
One of them are challenges
with tenant onboarding.
When we say onboarding
in SaaS, what we mean is
how quickly you can get your
customers from learning about
your product to getting
value out of your product.
This is one of the core
components of SaaS.
If your customers have a
bad onboarding experience,
if it takes them a week to
start using the software,
there's a pretty good
chance they've wandered off.
SaaS identity.
Again, what does it mean to authorize
and authenticate a user?
And how does tenant identity
and tenant context inject
itself into this process?
And how do we make sure that propagates
through our whole solution?
Data partitioning.
What does it mean to properly
manage our tenant data?
How do we segregate our
tenant data into either logic,
or physical buckets
that keeps the data safe
from other tenant's data?
Tenant isolation, what are the policies
that we use that define
what a tenant has access
to and what they don't?
This tenant can access this service,
this tenant can access this database
and they shouldn't ever
cross those boundaries.
Tenant resources should be specific
and explicitly defined for the tenant.
And finally, SaaS observability, right?
I've said that I would never
have a SaaS talk without
talking about observability.
The ability to monitor your
tenant's health applies across
the board to every SaaS solution.
In fact, I mean every solution,
if you're building a solution
and you're putting on AWS
and you don't have any
sort of observability,
I wanna have a conversation with you.
But if you're building an agentic solution
where there could be many moving parts,
I really wanna have a
conversation with you.
So with that Ujwal, could
you kind of kick us off
and tell us how we get
started with AgentCore
and agents in general?
- Sure.
So the topic of discussion today
is building multi-tenant agents using
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
So in there the fundamental component
as you folks can see is the agent.
So let's start with defining an agent
and then try to add more
layers on top of it.
So in here, now, I'll try
to obviously try to define
what an agent is,
but by now most of the
folks might be knowing
what an agent is.
So what I'll try to do is
when I'm trying to explain
what an agent is, try to highlight some
of the architecture challenges
you might encounter when
you're trying to build an agent.
To start off with, you'll
write just a piece of a code
and then you have to deploy that code
and run it in some kind of a compute.
Here, when you see that an agent,
assume that that is just
a piece of a code running
in some compute,
then you configure that agent
with a large language model
and then expose that
agent to your customers so
that they can interact
with that particular agent.
And then to extend the
functionality of the agent,
you need to write some tools code.
Tool, again, when I say
the tool is just a piece
of a code which will
help you to reach out,
which will help you to reach
out to some external system,
or external resource.
So, and again, at the end of the day,
the tool code has to run
in some kind of a compute
through which the agent tries
to reach out to some kind
of an AWS resource or some
other external resource.
Now that you have this agent,
the user might be interacting
with this agent.
So there is an inbound
call, which you might have
to authorize that inbound call
and the agent might be reaching
out to an external resource.
There is an outbound call, so
you need to do authorization
of that outbound call too.
So what I'm trying to
get to here is you need
to have some kind of an
identity which helps you with
that inbound authorization
of the inbound call
and also the authorization
of the outbound call.
And as you folks know,
when we talk about agents,
there should be some kind of
a memory management component
which you need to have so that you could
store the agent's conversation
memory so that the agent can
resolve a task assigned to it within
that particular context.
Last but not the least,
as Bill was mentioning,
we need some kind of an
observability component which will
help you to have eyes
and ears into the agent to understand
what an agent is doing,
why to particular decision
and all that good stuff.
So hopefully you can see that in here
when I define the agent, I
also try to touch upon some
of the architecture challenges
which you have encountered.
That brings us to the next
slide where I would like
to introduce you to the
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore,
which kinda addresses the
challenges which we have
established in the previous slide.
To start off with, you
could build your AgentCore
and deploy that in
AgentCore Runtime Primitive
to securely scale and
deploy your agent code.
And you can deploy your tools code
in an AgentCore Gateway Primitive.
Think of this primitive
as just MCP as a service.
And then you could
configure the agent running
in the AgentCore Runtime
with the AgentCore Gateway
through MCP so that it
can invoke those tools.
Now, again here, the
user invoking the agent
for the inbound call,
there is an inbound call
and the agent reaching out
to the external resources,
there is an outbound call to help
with those inbound authorization
and the outbound authorization,
we could use another primitive
called AgentCore Identity,
which will help you with those two calls.
And for the memory management,
you could use another primitive
call AgentCore memory,
which will have a short-term
memory, a long-term memory,
which we will talk in a bit here.
And then you could leverage
AgentCore observability,
which primarily as I mentioned earlier,
helps you to understand
why particular agent
is doing a particular
task in a certain way
and also helps you to capture any kind
of a custom metrics related
to that particular agent.
Last but not the least,
the AgentCore also gives you
some custom tools which you
could leverage if it makes
sense for your architecture.
So Bill, now that we have established some
of these fundamental
components, can you let us know
how we could bring in a
multi-tenants flavor here?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So again, when we think
about SaaS in general,
one of the concepts we
want to be thinking about
is how we want to deploy
our solution to get
to different types of customers.
And we very rarely with a
SaaS solution find ourselves
with a single archetype of customers.
We might want to go up
market to bigger customers,
we might wanna go down
market to smaller customers,
we might wanna have more configurability,
but there's different concerns
we have to think about.
The first of those is
how we apply multi-tenancy
in those different models.
When we talk about these,
there's a couple primary models
that really start to emerge.
The first of which you'll
hear us call either silo,
or dedicated.
Now, in a silo or dedicated model,
in fact, it's pretty straightforward,
everybody gets their own stack.
You get your own web server,
you get your own web server,
you get your own compute,
you get your own compute.
Everybody has their own
independent architecture,
usually top to bottom.
On the other extreme is pooled
or shared infrastructure.
And in here, it's an
entirely different challenge
and in fact most of the
architecture will be shared.
And at runtime we're gonna
have to make decisions.
Who are you?
What are you trying to do?
And do you have permission
to do the operations you're
currently trying to do?
And there are trade-offs
and those usually boil down
to a couple primary facts.
One, silo is a simpler architecture.
Any of us could take a
complete AWS stack, run it once
and then turn around, run
it another AWS account.
It's not very hard.
On the other hand, it's
also not terribly efficient.
If you think about it,
when you have two accounts,
it doesn't seem so bad.
What about when you have
a thousand accounts,
it's gonna get a lot harder to operate
and maintain that solution.
On the other side, we
have more complexity.
To really properly do
pooled or shared solutions,
we have to think deeply about
what the multi-tenant concerns are
and how we've handled them.
How do we apply governance?
How do we think about tenant isolation?
How have we done data partitioning?
All of those questions
become very, very important
and these trade-offs all become
in sort of different flavors
because you won't necessarily
make a clean choice
between these two.
You might just not have
a completely siloed,
or pooled architecture.
You might have a hybrid
or bridge architecture
where perhaps one piece
is completely shared,
other pieces are completely
dedicated, even all the way down
to a workload by workload decision,
you might be deciding is
this a pooled solution,
or is this a completely siloed solution?
So with that, Ujwal, hand it back to you
and talk a little bit
about multi-tenant agents
and how those fit into these
different deployment models.
- Sure.
So, so far we kind of
defined what an agent is
and we also got you
introduced to the AgentCore.
And then Bill has introduced us to some
of the multi-tenant concepts.
Let's try to bring all of them together
and try to build our agents,
or turn our agents into
multi-tenant agents.
So that, let's start with silo agent.
When I say a silo agent,
it's an agent dedicated
for a particular tenant.
The way you could create
that is you could have
your dedicated agent deployed in
a dedicated AgentCore runtime.
It can be configured with a
dedicated AgentCore memory.
And then you could extend that
agent with the tools core,
which are dedicated for
that particular tenant,
which are deployed in a
dedicated AgentCore Gateway,
which would reach out
to your dedicated
tenant-specific resources.
In this case, I'm just showcasing
some of the AWS resources
and also it can be a third party API.
This would be the silo
agent, whereas moving on
to the pool agent, similar
pattern using similar pattern
where you have your pool agent deployed
in a pool AgentCore runtime configured
with pool AgentCore runtime, sorry,
configured with the pool AgentCore memory.
And then it is also configured
with the pool AgentCore Gateway
where you have the pool tools
which are trying to reach out
to the pool AWS resources.
So again here when we introduce
a silo and pool model,
kind of like, we showcase
two extreme cases,
but in reality some of the components
of these components would be shared
and some of them would be dedicated.
So you would build a bridge,
or a hybrid model which Bill
was trying to elude earlier.
And again, I would like
to point your attention
to the AgentCore memory.
This is the first time where
I'm introducing short-term
memory and the long-term memory.
So let me briefly explain what those are.
Short-term memory is a memory where
you could store some raw
events on a per-session basis,
like user inputs, agent replies,
or any kind of a system level changes.
Long-term memory is a memory,
which you could leverage
to store conversation
summaries across the sessions,
or user preferences or any
kind of system level changes,
or system preferences.
You could store these things in there.
So now that we have established some
of the fundamental components
of some multi-tenant agents,
let's try to take these things
and start resolving the SaaS
architecture challenges,
which Bill has explained earlier.
To start off with, we'll
start with tenant onboarding.
So for the tenant onboarding
as SaaS best practice,
we have been always saying that,
or advocating that as a SaaS provider,
you need to build some kind
of a control plane experience
where it has bunch of services
like onboarding service,
tenant provisioning service,
or tenant management service,
tenant registration service.
All these services will
help you to manage, operate
and deploy or onboard your tenants.
When you're trying to onboard your tenant,
that's when your
tenant-specific architecture
will be deployed in a
SaaS application plane.
That's where your
multi-tenant architecture,
or your secret source lies in.
So now leveraging this SaaS control plane,
you could onboard a tenant
which would map to a silo model
and then you would provision
this silo architecture,
which you saw in the previous slide.
And since it's a silo model,
you could pretty much provision
these resources only when
you are onboarding a particular tenant,
because it is a dedicated resources plane.
Similarly, you would use the
same control plane experience
and you would onboard
another tenant, maybe the map
to a pool model where
you would provision this
infrastructure for that particular tenant.
Again, since this is a
pool model which is shared
across multiple tenants,
you could upfront provision,
or pre-provision this
particular infrastructure.
Similarly, you could
extend this experience
where if you could onboard
tenant three, which is mapping
to the pool model, then
you would just map it
to that particular model.
And the way you would expose these models
to your customers through
maybe through tiers,
in a sense you could have a
basic tier which is mapping
to a pool model,
or you could have a premium
tier which maps to a silo model.
So Bill, now that we have resolved one
of these SaaS architectural challenges,
can you set us the stage here
for resolving the next SaaS
architectural challenge?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So yeah, we're clicking
through our architectural
challenges one at a time.
We talked about onboarding,
let's get into identity a little bit.
Now, SaaS identity has
always been true across
all SaaS applications.
Some of the concepts
still remain the same.
Quick refresher, I want to go over some
of the primary tenants
and just a little bit
of a twist on why we think
about this slightly differently
when we're building AgentCore.
It's always been true we've
got tenant users coming in
and there's gonna be some
form of an identity provider.
We need something to
manage all of these users.
In our particular example, we
decided to use Amazon Cognito.
It is an identity provider
that does provide tenant
boundaries, the tenant boundaries,
and we have choices in Cognito,
but the one we chose to use
is a user pool per tenant.
So user pool per tenant simply means we've
got a nice tenant boundary.
All of our users for each
tenant are bucketed up nicely.
This particular user right
here belongs to tenant one
and as you can see, they've
got some custom claims,
or what we're calling custom
claims here on this user.
And the reason I say calling
custom claims is in fact if you
look in Cognito, we call
these attributes in Cognito,
but downstream, when
we instantiate and vent
to this JUUT token,
you're gonna find them
called custom claims
inside the JUUT token.
So we can have tenant status here,
any number of other
metadata about this user
that we wanna proliferate
through the rest of our application.
Now, the JUUT token is a
vehicle for how we pass
that data downstream.
And I want you to keep in mind,
if you haven't done JUUT
tokens before, it's okay,
we don't have to understand
this representation,
but in fact they're just
basically JSON in there.
And there's a couple different parts,
and this is kind of relevant
when we talk about AgentCore,
there's the identity token
which automatically inherits all
of the custom claims I
was just talking about.
That can be useful for some applications.
Sometimes you can simply rely
on that identity token alone.
On the other hand, there's another part
to the token which is
called the access token.
And the access token actually
doesn't inherently inherit all
of those custom claims
and the access token is going to be passed
around inside AgentCore.
One strategy we can use is
to use a pre-token
generation lambda trigger
that can take all of those custom claims
and copy them into the access
token, which can be convenient
for when you're passing it around
and you're gonna see usual talk about how
that access token is passed around
and reused at different
layers of AgentCore.
So Ujwal, could you walk us through what
that looks like in
AgentCore with the identity?
- Sure.
So now that
Bill has established how we need
to create a SaaS identity, now
let me walk you through here
how you could leverage AgentCore identity
and let the SaaS identity flow
through your architecture.
And also we'll walk you through
how you could leverage getting context
from that SaaS identity
and use the AgentCore identity primitive
and enforce authorization.
So earlier when I was
talking about the agent,
when you talk about the
agent, I mentioned that now
there are two types of
authorizations you have to do,
one for the inbound call and
another for the outbound call.
Inbound call comes into play
when a particular user is
invoking particular tenant,
which is running in some
kind of an AgentCore runtime environment,
or something on those lines.
The outbound authorization
comes into play when your agent
is trying to reach out
to an external system.
So in here I'll first talk about
how you could leverage AgentCore identity
and do the inbound authorization.
So my assumption here is
that you have some kind
of an identity provider.
You're configured in such
a way that it provides you
with a SaaS identity, which
Bill has explained earlier.
So now for your, when a
user hits your website,
you would redirect them
to the identity provider
where they will authenticate and it
generates identity token.
It can be an access token or an ID token,
but it has the user information
and also the tenant-specific information.
So basically it's a SaaS identity.
Using the JW token,
the tenants can invoke
the agents running in
the AgentCore runtime.
In here, I am just using AgentCore runtime
and deploying the agent code
and also the tools code here.
So now, now, the agent code runtime
has to authorize that particular
JW token coming from a
particular user invocation.
For that, you could
leverage agent core identity
where you could configure
your AgentCore runtime
with the AgentCore identity
and also you could configure
the AgentCore identity
with your identity provider.
So once you do this
configuration, AgentCore identity
will get hold of that inbound
JW token, talks to your IDP
and authorizes that particular call.
Once it authorizes that particular call,
then the JW token will be
available within the AgentCore runtime.
That's how the inbound
authorization can be implemented
using AgentCore identity.
Kinda like pretty straightforward thing.
Now, let's move on to the
outbound authorization.
For the outbound authorization,
this piece of an architecture which we saw
previously in the previous
slide, as I mentioned earlier,
the outbound authorization
comes into play when your agents
are trying to reach out
to an external resource.
Let's assume this external
resource is an AWS resource.
If it's an AWS resource,
you could piggyback on IAM,
you could leverage IAM
to authorize that call
where basically you'll
attach an execution role
to your AgentCore runtime,
which will authorize that particular call.
But things becomes interesting
when your tools are trying
to reach out to an external resource,
or an agent which expects
a auth token or an API key.
In those cases, you could
leverage AgentCore identity.
First, what you could do is
for those external resources,
they might have some kind of an IDP,
or some kind of credential provider,
you could configure your AgentCore entity
with those credential providers or IDPs.
Since you deployed your agent
in the AgentCore runtime,
AgentCore identity inherently what it does
is it creates a identity
for your each agent that's
called workload identities.
Just hold onto that
thought, in a bit second,
you will see how this
workload identity will be
leveraged by the AgentCore identity.
Now, using, again, using
the AgentCore identity,
you could bring in a
human in the loop where
you could surface a form,
or something where
saying to the user that,
"Hey, your tool is trying to reach out
to some external resource,
will you authorize this particular call?"
Assuming that the user has
authorized that particular call,
now, AgentCore runtime
and AgentCore identity
has to talk to each other
and generate a access token,
which will give access
to the tools to interact
with that external resources.
The way it does is the
AgentCore runtime makes a call
to AgentCore identity saying that,
"Hey, for this particular agent,
can you generate an access token?"
AgentCore identity takes that
request, maps that request
to an workload identity that
is identity of the agent,
and then in turn maps that
to the configured identity provider
and generates a workload access token.
Now, the agent tools using
this workload access token
can interact with the external resources.
Again, since you have
deployed these agents
in the AgentCore runtime,
all the steps which I just mentioned
happens out of the box
for you, all you just have
to do in the code is use one annotation.
That is the rate it requires access token,
then you'll get hold of that
particular access token.
The similar process happens
even for the API keys.
So now you can also bring
in a multi-tenant angle
for this outbound authorization.
Let's assume that your downstream
external resource or your,
this downstream external
resource can be some third party
API or it can be some other service within
your organization.
They're expecting some
more additional information
within that access token,
that workload access token.
That additional information
can be metadata,
or tenant-specific information.
You could pretty much build that into it
by leveraging AgentCore identity.
The way you can do that is
since the AgentCore identity
is already configured
with the identity providers,
that external identity providers
can customize the workflow,
which generates the access
token and add the custom claims.
The thing which I'm alluding
here is the one which Bill has
explained when he's
explaining the SaaS identity.
Assuming that you've
implemented that thing here,
now, AgentCore identity,
when it generates this
workload access token,
it can also have this additional
metadata which you could
pass into the external resources.
So now, so far, when we talked
about all this good stuff,
we are only talked in the
context of AgentCore runtime.
But again, all the best practices
of the things which I talked about here
will still apply for the
AgentCore Gateway too.
The way it looks is this is
the same architecture which
you saw in the previous slide.
The only difference here is
that the tools code now is
deployed in the AgentCore Gateway
and it is reaching out to
the external resources.
Now the agent code running
in the AgentCore runtime can,
using the JWT inbound
JW token can reach out,
or make the call to the AgentCore Gateway
and the AgentCore
Gateway can be configured
with AgentCore identity to do
that authorization of
that particular request.
Additionally, AgentCore
Gateway has a new feature
called Gateway Interceptor,
which can intercept
the request coming into
that particular AgentCore Gateway
and get hold of all the headers in it
and you could also get
hold of the JW token
and from that JW token, you
could make that available
for your tools or you could
also get the tenant context
from it and then leverage
those things here.
So Bill, now moving on to
the next data partitioning
SaaS architecture challenges,
can you just do a quick recap
and set the stage for us here?
- Right on.
I told you the identity
part was hard, right?
That's probably the hardest part.
I promise you none of 'em
gonna be quite as challenging.
Data partitioning is actually
pretty straightforward
to think about.
As we mentioned, it's
really how we bucket up
our tenant data.
What are the challenges we face?
Well, there's cost challenges,
there's operational challenges,
but there's only so many
ways we can do this.
You have to have some sort of separation,
logical or physical between the data.
Now, in terms of data partitioning,
we've kind of seen some
hints already, right?
We've heard the term, memory,
so memory probably makes us
think there's gonna be some
partitioning somewhere and
we've seen some downstream AWS
services too that might
need to be partitioned.
So Ujwal, let me add it back to you.
Tell us a little bit about
how we can apply data
partitioning in AgentCore.
- Sure.
So when we say about
the data partitioning,
so it's basically you
need to look at the areas
where in this architecture
you're dealing with data.
One area is with the AgentCore memory
where you're storing
the tenant-specific data
and the other area is the AWS resources.
In here, we are just
showcasing a knowledge base
and the DynamoDB table.
Now, let's pick these two
areas and double click into it
and understand how you could
implement data partitioning
when it's a silo model or a pool model.
To start off with, Silo AgentCore
Memory where you have a,
as I mentioned earlier,
you have dedicated AgentCore runtime.
In here you have a dedicated agent.
The white box, which I'm showcasing is,
think of this as an
agent implementation code
and then you would have a
Dedicated AgentCore Memory
specific to that particular tenant.
And if you have multiple
tenants then you see something
like this.
Now, let's say if the
agent is trying to make,
or create an event in
the short-term memory,
the way it can create an
event in the short-term memory
is it needs a memory ID.
Memory ID is a unique ID
created when you are creating
a AgentCore memory and
then it needs a session ID
as I mentioned earlier,
in the short-term memory,
you store the events by session ID.
So each session ID,
for each session you
have a unique session ID
and then you need some
kind of an actor ID.
Think of this actor ID as a unique key
for your agent or for the user.
Other way to look at this is think of this
as a primary key kind of
a thing in our database
kind of thing.
Here, what convention you could use
is you could partition the data
by tenant ID calling subject.
These values are coming
from your input JW token
and then making this tenant
ID, sorry, this actor ID
as tenantid subject,
you're making it unique for
that particular tenant user.
That way you're kind of
partitioning the data
by that particular ID.
For the long-term memory,
the way the long-term memory
stores the information
is by namespaces and
what you could see there
is the convention which you have
to use for naming the namespaces.
And in here I would like
to point your attention
towards the actor ID there.
So before I do that,
you see some variables
with the curly braces, right?
Those are nothing but the variables
where you could inject
the values in real time.
So leverage that same actor
ID in this namespace so
that you have a unique namespace
for that particular tenant user so
that the data is partitioned that way.
But again, I would like to
point your attention back
to the actor ID is equal to tenant ID
and subject where my assumption here is
that I wanna partition
the data by tenant users,
but for some reason if you
wanna just partition by tenant,
then in those cases the actor ID
can be just a tenant ID idea.
But again, in that, the follow-up
question there would be,
if that is the case then this
convention might not be a big
help for you folks because
you're already creating
a dedicated memory for
that particular tenant.
So it might not be of much help,
but this convention comes
in handy when you move
to the pool model where
you are creating a pool
agent in a pooling runtime
environment, which is
interacting with a pool memory,
which is shared across multiple tenants.
And now when this agent
is trying to reach out
to the short-term memory,
it uses this convention
where you're basically partitioning
the data by tenant user.
And similarly, when you're interacting
with the long-term memory, you
could use this namespace with
that actor ID so that you're partitioning
for each of the tenant user.
And now, I'll quickly
walk you through some
of the AWS resources which you have seen,
which you have been seeing
in this architecture
and talk about how you could
partition the data there.
To start off with, we'll do
this knowledge base, silo model,
you create a dedicated
knowledge base for each
of your tenant, which is configured
with a dedicated vector
database and pool model,
you could have a pool knowledge
base which is configured
with a pooled vector store,
which is shared across multiple tenants.
In here, the way that
the data is partitioned
or tagged here is that
when you're talking about
a pool knowledge base,
you would ingest all the
tenant-specific data,
along with that, it also provides,
Amazon knowledge base
provides you a feature
where you could attach
additional metadata to it.
So what you could do is when
you're ingesting the data into
the knowledge base, you could
also attach the tenant ID
to it so that the data goes in there
even though it's living
in the knowledge base,
it is kind of tagged with
that particular tenant ID.
You will see that how this will be useful
for you later when you're trying
to pull the tenant-specific
data from this shared,
or pool knowledge base.
Applying the same principle
for another AWS resource,
Amazon DynamoDB table, silo model would be
table per tenant or a pool
model would be single table
shared across multiple tenants.
But you would have a tenant
that has a partition key.
So that is unique for
the particular tenant.
Applying the same principle for S3 bucket,
you would create a silo model
would be bucket for each
of your tenant, whereas a
pool model you would create
a prefix for each
of your particular tenant
within the same bucket.
So now moving on to the next
SaaS architecture challenges,
partitioning the data is not enough.
We need to make sure that
particular tenant is able
to only get tenant-specific resources.
That's what the definition
of tenant isolation.
So now, what we'll do is we'll go back
to the all the areas where
we partition the data
and see how we could
implement tenant isolation
for those areas.
To start off with, again, we'll go back
to the Silo AgentCore Memory.
You have this dedicated
agent which is interacting
with your AgentCore,
Dedicated AgentCore Memory.
And then with the short-term memory
and the long-term memory, it
is using this namespace prefix,
which you've defined.
Since it is a dedicated resource,
you could pretty much
piggyback on IAM where
you could attach an execution role
to this AgentCore runtime,
which gives access only
to the tenant-specific resources.
That's how you could enforce
tenant isolation here.
But again, the assumption
which I'm making here is
that if you look at the actor ID,
which is equal to tenant ID
where I'm kind partitioning
the data only by tenant.
If you wanna, even in the
silo model, if you wanna do
partition by tenant ID
and the tenant user level,
then this might not be handy for you.
You need to do a little bit
more fine grain authorization
to enforce tenant isolation,
which you will learn
when we are talking about the pool model.
Again, for the pool model,
you have the pool agent
running in a pool runtime
and then it is interacting
with the pool memory,
short-term memory using this actor ID
and the namespace.
In here, since it is pool
shared across multiple tenants,
what you could do is the agent can
assume this particular
role, basically you have
to create some kind of ABAC role.
This is nothing but an
attribute-based access control role.
In that role, if you look
at the highlighted area,
what I'm trying to do there is
I'm putting a condition saying that,
"Hey, give access to these
contents in this memory
only for this actor ID."
And then similarly for
the long-term memory,
you could have another IAM
policy which has this condition
which is giving only access
to that particular namespace.
So now trying to sum up
everything together here,
the pool agent from the JW
token gets the tenant context,
it can create the actor ID with tenant ID
and the subject, inject that
actor ID into this IAM policy
and then it can interact with
a security token service.
It's another service
through which it assumes
this particular role
and get some scope credentials which are
specific to this particular tenant.
And using those credentials
it can only access,
or interact with tenant-specific
data in the shared,
or the pool AgentCore memory.
That's how you would enforce
tenant isolation in this model.
Now, moving on to the
AWS resources silo model.
You have siloed agents running
in the silo tenant AgentCore runtime,
which is interacting with
silo tools which interacts
with the silo resources.
Again, since everything is siloed,
you could piggyback on IAM resources
where you could create an
execution role or IAM role,
which gives access only to
tenant-specific resources
and you can attach those
execution role to the pool tools,
or to your AgentCore runtime,
which will give you only
that particular access.
Pretty straightforward.
Whereas a pool AWS resources, again,
you have the pool agent
running interacting
with the pool tools, which
goes to the pool resources.
In here when you're
implementing the isolation
for some AWS services, like what you saw
in the AgentCore memory
and for other service
Amazon DynamoDB table,
you have good integration with IAM
where you could create an
attribute-based access control
role and then enforce isolation.
But for some reasons it won't be the case.
But let's speak how in
this case, let's talk about
how you would implement
with DynamoDB table.
Similar to what you have seen earlier,
you could create an IAM role, ABAC role,
which gives only permission to
that particular DynamoDB table item in
that particular DynamoDB table.
If you look at the
highlighted piece there,
you're kind of creating a
condition there saying that,
"Hey, for this particular tenant only
give only this particular tenant items."
So now in this case the
pool tools from the JW token
get the tenant ID, injects
that into the ABAC role
and gets the scope credentials,
using the scope credentials,
it can interact with the DynamoDB.
But if you move towards
the pool knowledge base,
you cannot, pool knowledge
base as of today,
doesn't provide you way to do
implement this ABAC approach.
But in turn you can
piggyback on another feature
provided by the pool knowledge base,
or the knowledge base is
called metadata filtering.
So if you remember earlier
when I talked about
the pool knowledge base, I said,
as a best practice when you're ingesting
this tenant-specific data,
attach tenant-specific
metadata like tenant ID to it
and the data would be tagged to it.
Now, using this metadata filtering,
what you could do is you could pull
only tenant-specific data
by using your tenant ID.
Think of this as like a
SQL query you are making
and you need to attach a
aware clause like tenant ID
is equal to the tenant ID value.
So to put it in the context,
the pool tools from the JW
token gets the tenant ID,
constructs that metadata
filtering query with the tenant ID
and gets only tenant-specific
resources from
this pool knowledge base.
So that's how you could
enforce tenant isolation
for this case.
Now, let me hand it over
to Bill to help us run
through the next SaaS
architecture challenge.
- Right on.
So you probably gathered already
that I feel pretty seriously
about observability in
a SaaS application.
So let's get into some of the details of
what we mean when we're talking
about applying observability
in a multi-tenant solution.
So in general, the challenges
around SaaS observability
haven't exactly changed
in an agentic world.
There are some specifics that do change,
but overall we still have tenants
and they're calling specific resources.
In this case they happen to be agents.
We could apply the same
practice if we were using
microservices or features.
All of these calls need
to be instrumented.
Now, typically you'll have logs,
you might emit activity events,
you might pick consumption events,
whatever you're emitting
out of your application,
you need to inject tenant
SaaS context into that,
which includes tenancy.
What does that look like?
It might look something like this, right?
It might be a simple JSON
that has agents and tiers,
tenant IDs and regions.
It could be any number of other items.
Really this is an exercise in reaching out
to our business users
who will operate their
business intelligence tools
and finding out how they wanna
slice and dice this data.
Because especially with
agents with the expense
that can be added onto your
solution, they're gonna have
to be rethinking how they're
pricing the solution.
They're gonna be thinking about
how their customers are
consuming the solution.
All of those are measured
by sending out metrics which
will allow their analytics
to operate the business more efficiently.
Now, as we mentioned,
AgentCore has an observability component.
So we've talked about runtime,
we've talked about the gateways
and the identity, the memory,
all of these things we've sort of covered.
I think probably a nice
telling slide though is all
of these things, each of the
pieces we've talked about
so far are directly tied
into observability already.
This is one of the really nice things
that they've done in AgentCore,
because this isn't built
up from scratch product,
instead of observability
being a bolt on that somebody
thinks on after the fact, like, "Oh yeah,
I guess we should probably
do some observability."
It's there from the start
and all of the different components
of AgentCore can actually send
observability off to there
and in fact it has some
nice built-in tools already,
like an open telemetry
implementation, open telemetry,
what we call the Addock
SDK that we can use
to send the tenant ID
off of custom metrics.
It has a nice integration
with CloudWatch already.
I think if you haven't used
it yet, write an agent,
have it do some logs
and you're gonna find a
pretty nice agentic dashboard
that already exists in
CloudWatch that you could use
to troubleshoot your agents
and understand in general what it means
to see the operation of your agents.
Now, this is a bit of a rant,
tenant ID is not a first class
concept in observability.
It isn't for CloudWatch,
it isn't for our third party solutions.
It rarely is anywhere.
And this kind of makes sense,
not everything is a SaaS solution, right?
So there are solutions out
there that don't need tenant ID.
So when we're slicing and dicing our data
and thinking about how we do this,
it usually comes down to custom metrics
and custom dashboards when we're building
multi-tenant solutions.
Because tenant ID has
to be a first class
concept when we're building
multi-tenant solutions.
And this is just as true
for agents as anywhere else.
While the AgentCore built in
dashboards can be very helpful,
you're very likely still going to have
to compliment those with custom
dashboards that you create
that revolve around your tenant ID.
Now, why is this so important?
Why is observability so
important in multi-tenancy?
One example that we almost
always end out talking
to our customers about is
understanding the unit economics
of SaaS.
What is the cost of operating
an individual tenant?
How do we measure that?
And the answer is it's
actually not that easy to do.
We have to build some custom observability
and we have to emit custom metrics.
Now, when we talk about this,
one of the things we say is,
because this is hard to
do, we wanna prioritize
what we want to measure.
What's the expensive part
of an agentic solution?
Usually it's our models.
All of those, all those
invocations actually add up,
the inference costs are
probably the primary thing that
your business is gonna
be raising their hand
and saying, "Hey, why does
this thing cost so much?"
And the answer to that is
to actually measure the token's input
and output out of the LLM
with your observability,
you can see this is
actually pretty simple code.
This is just a custom
library recording metrics
that do the model indications.
It counts the number of
input and output tokens.
We're gonna collect those
and we're gonna pass them
downstream so our agents can
send those off to CloudWatch
and CloudWatch can collect those
and you can start to see that
the tenant-specific metrics
are flowing through.
And if we're using CloudWatch,
we can certainly get
to the point where we can filter those
with CloudWatch log insights, right?
So logged insights is a
simple query language.
If you're using Datadog,
if you're using New Relic,
if you're using Honeycomb,
they all have their own query languages.
It's not like if you're
using third parties
it'll be any different, but this is ours.
And if you look there, you don't even have
to understand the whole thing,
just look toward the bottom
and you'll see some by tenant ID.
And that's really all this
query is doing for us.
It's taking all those
indications, breaking them down
by tenant so that in
turn we can pass that off
to our observability tools.
Or in the case of what
we're gonna try to do here,
use those to calculate the
actual cost per tenant.
So here what we're gonna do on
the next step is we're gonna
correlate our agent usage
with the actual costs.
So we've already done the first part,
we've already actually created
the CloudWatch insights.
So maybe we use a Lambda to
occasionally invoke that,
take those costs and get the
actual underlying costs, right?
So we've got usage, what is
the cost and usage report say?
How much did it cost for each
one of those invocations?
Combine those two concepts
and perhaps we could
store them in DynamoDB
and they might look something like this,
tenant one having so many invocations.
Now that we've broken down our individual
inference cost per tenant,
we can visualize those
perhaps with QuickSight or another BI tool
and create nice dashboards that
our business users can drive
to understand a deeper understanding
of what it means to operate our tenants.
Cost per tenant might
look something like this
and cost per tier might look
something like this, right?
Where we can actually say,
"Okay, this is about the cost per tenant."
And tools like QuickSight
with their own integrations
with models now can also let
those business users drill into
those individual tiers
and see how much it costs
for the tenants inside those tiers.
As long as we've
provided 'em with that data,
it's our responsibility
as the builders of the
agent to emit that data
that unlocks all of those cases
where business users can actually
drill down into this data
and understand what's
happening under the hood.
With that, Ujwal,
we started off with the
sample architecture.
Could you take us back to
the sample architecture
and walk through it with all
of the different things
we've talked about today
and talk about how they
apply to that architecture?
- Sure, yep.
So now I'll present you the
same sample architecture,
but let's look from the lens
of what we have learned,
in order to touch upon the things here.
To start off with,
the architecture which I'm
presenting would ease pool model,
which is all shared
across multiple tenants.
So what you see is we
created a bunch of agents,
which are deployed in a
pool AgentCore runtime.
And these agents are shared
across multiple tenants
and they're configured with
a large language model.
And hopefully you could see
that we are using SaaS
framework to build these agents.
And then we are using a supervisor pattern
where you have an orchestrator
agent, which is configured
with a bunch of sub-agents.
Now, when you assign a task
to this particular orchestrator agent,
it will invoke the knowledge base agent,
which will in turn try
to invoke a tool, again,
which is a knowledge base
tool which is shared across
multiple tenants,
which is deployed in a
Pool AgentCore Gateway,
which is interacting with
a pooled knowledge base,
which is again plugged in
with a pooled vector database.
So everything is shared
across multiple tenants.
And one, assuming that you know,
the orchestrator agent
did not get a meaty answer
for this particular request
from this particular subagent
that is a knowledge base agent,
then it would invoke the log
analysis agent, which in turn configured
to use this log analysis
agent to pull the data
from the S3 bucket,
which has the application
logs where we have
all the tenant-specific application logs.
And then in here, this
whole architecture, again,
you will see in this work workshop that,
we have used a SaaS control plane
and tenant onboarding experience
to provision this pool model
into the SaaS application play.
And then from the SaaS
identity concepts perspective,
again you will see that when
you're invoking this agent,
what we do is we ask for your credentials
where you authenticate you against an ATP,
and then generate a JW token,
which is nothing but an access token,
which has the tenant information in it
and then the tenant information,
using the JW token, you
would invoke this agent,
which is running AgentCore runtime.
Then as we talked earlier,
we use AgentCore identity
to authorize that particular request
and make the JW token available
for the agents within
the AgentCore runtime.
And then those agents would, again,
when they're making a call
to the tools in the AgentCore Gateway,
use the JW token again there
to authorize that particular call.
We use AgentCore identity
and again here,
we are only trying to
interact with AWS resources.
But again, as I mentioned earlier,
you could extend AgentCore
identity concepts,
apply for the outbound
authorization calls also
when you're trying to reach out
to an external resource or external agent.
From the data partitioning point of view,
the areas where you need
to do the data partitioning
is obviously,
as we discussed earlier,
the knowledge base,
the knowledge base is shared
across multiple tenants.
We used, as we talked about
using metadata filtering
concept, we ingest the data
with tenant-specific data in it
and we partition the data in that way.
Whereas for the log analysis tool agent,
we have a shared S3 bucket.
We have partitioned the
data with prefix per each
of the tenant with the
prefix name as a tenant ID.
And then for enforcing the
tenant isolation, again,
going back to the knowledge base,
we use a metadata filtering
where the knowledge base
tool from the JW token gets
the tenant context
and then uses the tenant context
using metadata filtering,
tries to get only
tenant-specific resources,
or tenant-specific data from the Amazon
Bedrock Knowledge Base.
And whereas for the tool analysis agent,
the way we enforce isolation
here since S3 bucket
has a good integration with ABAC,
or a attribute-based access control role.
This basically has a
good integration with IAM
where you could create an ABAC role.
So log analysis tool,
what it does is from the JW
token, gets tenant context,
injects that into the ABAC role
and gets access only
to the tenant-specific application
logs within that prefix
of that particular
tenant in the S3 bucket.
That's how it enforces tenant isolation.
And then last but not the
least, as Bill mentioned,
we used AgentCore
observability specifically
to capture the tenant-specific
metrics related to the number
of input tokens and output tokens
generated for that particular tenant.
When the agents are
executing a particular task
and takes those things
and logs using AgentCore observability,
we log it to the CloudWatch logs.
So hopefully you can see
that where we started off,
where we introduced you folks
to all the different concepts
and we'll try to bring them all together
and try to build an
architecture which would
check all the boxes of
what we talked about.
So that's all we had for you folks today.
Hopefully this is helpful for you folks.
- And don't forget about the
workshop that that is today
and tomorrow, right?
- Yep, yes.
- Today and tomorrow.
Definitely, it's worth waiting in line for
if you haven't signed up already.
Thank you, everybody.
- Thank you.
(hands clap)